ah
Star Wars is one of my favorite movies
specifically a new hope the trench run
is not only super iconic but it's one my
favorite scenes in the movies we got his
little drones these are newbie drones
they're basically mini Thai fighters our
ex witness and that gave me an idea what
if we recreate the trench run in real
life which I had everybody save their
boxes and here at this building for like
two weeks straight
Wade built our very own trench run and
we're going to try to see if we are as
good as Luke Skywalker can we do the
trench run how hard is it and at the end
we had to blow up the Death Star there's
a fat going to be a little vent port you
have to fly our drone through if we use
the Force turns out we're a Jedi
easy-peasy
I have a feeling it's getting really
hard it might be really hard to know if
the reason is because I was up late
smoking sausages the true story
the ghost made all these sausages the
other day and was like hey Sam you got a
smoker you wanna help me smoke these
sausages yeah swing by around 8:00 and
he shows a bit like 9:00 and like dude
I'm a dad I have bedtime it takes three
hours to smoke the sausage is delicious
didn't sleep hey Nico are you gonna be
flying in stable mode or air mode just
like an air mode
[Music]
[Music]
see my kids up the ante way too hard
yellow I do the trench
we got way too many people in the trench
to stay out of the stupid trench it
denies please don't hear another drone
up
find us as an English accent yes got an
a he's got a cockney accent written are
you weren't even helmet yes all this
commotion oh yeah it's gusty out of the
trench man
[Music]
how's it going you go hard I'm gonna
need you can't talk at the same time fly
[Music]
[Music]
all right I'm no Luke Skywalker well you
know I thought I was gonna be Porkins
[Laughter]
all right so it's the plan here
maybe I'm up smoking meats all night I
would have more energy for this good
luck all right I'm sorry that's what
they say all right here we go yeah nice
and slow passing those tourists like
they said yeah yeah boys losing my
orientate errs
knee up knee up to the rescue you get to
the vent the vent the air for the AC
vent vs now I'm just a blue ghost like
Yoda
[Music]
hey Ren yeah I'm gonna increase your
challenge no boy what are you gonna jam
Tim I may the force be with me lost
alone
believe in you read I believe in me
frizzy Syrian down the trench
you guys gotta get out the trench man
revelry
horse
I got this dude
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah well nice twist here so you know
you know the problem yeah as we're just
here being enemies we need to be on the
same squadron yeah yeah so right now I
gonna fly oh it says read one and read
two here down the trench where most is
gonna tread teamwork it if the two of us
working together can't hit that and it
turns out maybe it is a really rare
thing to be a Jedi patrons wonderful
happy people to support us in making
these videos every single day I'm
talking about you Philip Oxford Gary
dull did you guys actually know he's
related to Gandalf cutting red mention
that last time and of course I'd never
forget about Nicholas Psaltis or G
squared thank you guys very much
there's also not a Canadian spy will
Robertson Eddie Adolf [ __ ] Lensky
glitch cube James Bailey and Brian and
Toshi you know what would be great it
isn't as if we could just dupe donuts
all day together all day
go to patreon.com/scishow all recision
you guys are interested in doing donuts
in the hallway
I'm ready to go
three two one go
[Music]
about this
right
bravery around
right Anika remember the green tunnel
[Music]
[Applause]
man we just defeated the Empire sigh I
built 30 more Death Star's I can't
believe we made it through the whole
that's crazy is that was way harder than
I thought it'd be it's one thing to be
like practicing by yourself and blanks
low it's another thing to have like five
dudes running around like shooting at
you and like shinin light you know kind
of look like you're not apply at the
room I said yeah yeah damn it